alexey navalny's final moments in court
before the verdict was handed down
a last chance to communicate with his
wife to show how much he loves her
guilty the judge found of violating his
parole when recovering from novichok in
germany
jail term brought down to a little more
than two and a half years
because of time already spent under
house arrest
[Music]
lovers
his lawyer says they will appeal
outside the courtroom through the day
the riot police were primed for a now
familiar process
one arrest after another
some of them brutal ahead of a visit by
the eu's top man this friday
the kremlin spokesman had this to say uh
[Music]
um
but it will happen sanctions already
under consideration
the foreign secretary dominic rabb
blasting the ruling is perverse
and demanding navalny's immediate
release
[Music]
as night fell the kremlin had prepared
for more protests
this is hardly police this feels like we
are following
an army there is an absolutely
massive police deployment through the
streets
of central moscow in the wake of the
navalny hearing
but you can hear the car horns blurring
their support
not for the police for alexei navalny
and for people who've come out to
protest
this looks like a city and a country on
edge
a political crisis of the kremlin's
making the face of authoritarian rule
dyna magnay sky news moscow